I popped off to a a a
a what an
africanamerican say on a
plane you said it was way worse than any
way other way you could say it that's
worse than N
word stronger than the N word right now
wow dude I feel uncomfortable that was
uncomfortable we might even have to
bleep that we going to bleep him saying
African am that was wild cancel material
dude AF oh God I waa dude it was a chill
in my spine you feel it I yeah and my
body kind of shivered a bit holy [__] D
no dude no so
continue black dude on a plane yeah and
yeah Black Sam Jackson movie yeah uh oh
yeah he didn't give his seat up to a a
pregnant woman he was sitting in my seat
and I I was like oh hey I think that's
my
seat and he gets up and then a guy goes
hey do you mind actually you have an
aisle seat do you mind I have an aisle
seat do you mind switching seats my wife
has a middle seat and she's pregant he
goes yeah actually I do mind and I go oh
hey you you can have my seat and we were
switching I go I goes thank you so much
I go oh no problem and you you're an
[__] you said that well you said to
the africanamerican yes
the way you said
it the
african-amer you said that different
type of
aa oh wow yeah but it was coming back
African Aman do dude it was
coming it was coming back from skankfest
till all of our friends are peppered on
the and they're all like T tattooed
weird and well they're like texting
we're on a group chest like what the
[__] is going on I'm like don't worry
I'm
right yeah but uh you know we settled it
too we settled it too we bickered back
and forth and then I said look at us
we'd make a good buddy cop film huh and
then uh you fine with it yeah and then
we fist bumped and uh he kept his mask
on the whole time because he [__]
drank the Kool-Aid with the fouchy
alchie
sorry I have a question for
you
I have a question for you cuz Bobby's
terrified of middle seats like he will
have a full-blown panic attack let's say
it's a flight to New York 5 to 6 hours
and in my life now yeah in your life now
yeah um you are in coach for some reason
you needed to get somewhere and they
didn't have any other first class seats
yeah I'm not I'm not going on the flight
no way no that's not the question you're
already committed to being on the flight
you're now boarded you're boarded you're
boarded you're locked in oh so I don't
know how to read a ticket with the what
the [__] is a
scenario but look I don't know you get
there listen listen Okay your premium
economy your premium economy you have a
window seat right comfortable enough
enough leg room they fine you I'll get
on that okay but listen that's not
that's not the question pregnant woman
yes pregnant woman who has um is she
crowning she's about eight and a half
maybe nine 36 weeks let's say I don't
know how long that is but yes but she's
very pregnant but she's just like look
like I really need to be on your seat
because I need to lean this way and have
some support in this way but then she
has a middle
seat and she's next to
me yes I would have to switch mhm
because if she was in a different aisle
say now why but imagine if I said no you
sat there and she sat there the whole
time staring staring at you yeah and
she's just like you know what I mean I
couldn't do that no but she's a
different row I would say no well why
would she ask you specifically exactly
in a different R it's just the only
aisle seat here baby she just she looks
for you walks up see that
africanamerican over there yeah yeah so
you would give it up and have a panic
attack if yeah that's she was to thing
to do yes yeah but it would be a
bummer it would be a bummer what would
you do would you like you know give her
no you know it's so funny that you ask
that this is silly well you're you're
playing silly games with me I've done
that before what I've switched seats
before with people I know I know that
you're a really like sweet guy in that
way but I know you had a panic attack
being you feel claustrophobic I hat it
would be the five but if if do I have my
medication yeah okay I'm fine okay
you're good dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's really
sweet you know you guys are friends
again okay thought you were Mr free
seexual guy yeah too much too much all
right so um yeah any but um yeah I would
what would you do yeah of course did
yeah he did oh you did yeah